อ่ะมาค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะครูต้องสวัสดีค่ะครูเองสวัสดี
ค่ะนะ RE เรียนทุกคนค่ะเองสบายดีไหมคะ
สบายดีค่ะค่ะแข็งแรง
บอมบอมตัวเองเสร็จแล้วยังกูโอเคมั้ยพอดี
พูดทองทุกวันอาทิตย์พูดมากๆค่ะนักเรียน
พูดเยอะกูเองเจ็บคอไหม
เออนิดนึง
ต้องฟังเสียงพระเอกโอเคไหมกูเอ๋มีเสียง 2
ได้
มากค่ะถ้าเจ็บคอมากๆกูเอกก็เสียงซ้อม
สวัสดีค่ะ
เสียง
เล็กๆแน่จริงๆเสียงหนึ่งนะคะนักเรียน
เสียงสวัสดีค่ะแล้วครูเอง
เอาเสียง 2 เขาเป็นถ้า
นักเรียนมีผู้ชายเยอะๆถ้ากูเอกสวัสดีค่ะ
ค่ะนักเรียนออกนี่ค่ะเหมือนครูเอ๋นี่ก็
ไม่ต้องสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีเสียงของแรงเอาค้า
แต่ครูต้องมีเสียงเดียวนะต้องเป็นผู้หญิง
ไง
เมื่อก่อนเมื่อก็
ไม่ก่อน 30 ปีที่แล้วครูเอกก็เสียงผู้
หญิงขอพูดแล้วนักเรียนก็สวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนผู้ชายพูดสวัสดีค่ะครูเอกก็เลยต้อง
สวัสดีค่ะ
ออกแรงให้นักเรียนผู้ชายฟังแล้วสวัสดี
ครับเอ้าโอเคเสียงหล่อนะคะฟังและ b นายก
ไก่กูต้อมว่าผู้ต้องเราไม่ต้องเขียนวันก็
ได้เนาะคลิปเนี้ย
ใช่คุณต้อมคะครูต้องวันนี้ประมาณ 21:00 น
21:00 น 21:00  25 เหว๋
[เพลง]
มาทำงานที่บ้านสบายๆราคะคู๋สบายมาก
ได้เหนื่อยก็เรียงนอนนอน
โอ้ยเหนื่อยก็
นั่งนอนไม่ได้กูต้องต้องนั่งอยู่ในรถเอ้า
กูต้องไปข้างนอกหนูต้องขับรถเหรอคะ
กูต้องขับรถไปค่ะอ่ามีรถนะคะ
รถถนนเป็นยังไงคะคุณต้อมวันอาทิตย์รถไม่
ติดใช่ไหม
เห้อกูต้อมคิดว่ารถไม่ติดอ่ะไม่ติดใช่ไหม
มีรถนิดหน่อยใช่ไหมคะ
ไม่ใช่เลยค่ะ
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์นะวันอาทิตย์รถเยอะ
มากๆรถติดเกาะกูดมีรถเยอะมากค่ะมีรถ
ปุ๊บ
รถรถไม่ไปใช่ไหม
รถติดรถติด
ป่ากรุงเทพรถติด
มากๆแต่ว่าปี
2020 ถึง
2022 ประมาณเดือนเดือนมีนาคมค่ะ
นะคะรถไม่ติดนะ
เดือนนี้เดือนที่ห้าเดือนที่ 5 เนี่ย
เดือนเดือนพฤษภาคมพฤษภาคม
เดือน
พฤษภาคม
ขอโทษนะคะเดือนพฤษภาคมวันนี้วันที่เท่า
ไหร่ล่ะ 29  29 ใช่ค่ะปีพ.ศ
f22b ของ
2022 รถติดอีกแล้วหรอคะปิดฆ่าหมูโอ๋
ตกใจกูเองไม่ได้ออกจากบ้านไกลๆกูเอกก็
เดินเดินเดินแล้วก็ซื้ออาหารแล้วก็เดิน
เดินเดินกลับบ้านรถไม่ติดโว้ยกูต้อมแล้ว
เวลาเวลารถติดกูต้อง
สบายๆหรือ
เครียด
กูต้มเบื่อเบื่อเบื่อเบื่อเบื่อ
พ่อ
เหอะ
เดี๋ยวก็เห็นลืมถามกูต้องออกจากบ้านกี่
โมงนะคะกูต้มออกจากบ้านสิ 11:00 นคุยถ้า
อยากจะกินอีกรอบนะคะนักเรียนค่ะครูต้อม
เนี่ยออกจากบ้าน 11:00 น
เอเอ็มเวลาออกจากบ้านรถติดไหมคะ
11 โมงไม่ติดค่ะแล้วรถติดตอนไหนคะอะนิ
บาร์ติดตอน 17:00 นถาการณ์ออกจากบ้านรถ
ไม่ติดไม่ติดขอแต่ตอนคุณต้องจะกลับบ้าน
17:00 นโมงเย็นขอรถติดตอนกลับบ้าน
เหนื่อยลูกเหนื่อยมากคุณต้องไปทำงานมา
อยากจะกลับบ้าน
รถที่นานมาก
หูแล้วอย่างนี้กูต้องเอ่อหิวข้าวไหมคะกู
ต้องก็แม่ซื้อขนมเล็กๆมากินกินที่ในรถที่
ในรถใครทางรถหน่อย
หน้า
กูต้อมแล้วคุณใต้เดือนนะ 17:00 นถึงบ้าน
กี่โมง
17:00 นถึงบ้าน
19:00 นถึงบ้าน
19:00 น
6:00 น 2 ชั่วโมง 2 ชั่วโมงค่ะโอ้โห
2 ชั่วโมงนักเรียน
โห 2 ชั่วโมงอันนี้
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ฮ่างเหมิด
แล้วก็ขับรถขับรถวน
จากที่จอดรถค่ะตรงมาที่ถนน
ค่ะค่ะติดแต่ในห้างไหนเหรอคะข้างก็ติด
แล้วค่ามาที่ถนนก็ติดมาที่ถนนก็ติดอีกขอ
ก็เบื่อ
เบื่อเครียดไหมเครียดไหม
ๆ
ง่วงมาของง่วงนอนด้วยเฮ้ย
กูต้มถ้าเกิดเครียดแล้วรถติดมันก็เหนื่อย
ทำยังไงดีคุณต้อง
ถ้ามึงต้องก็มีวิธี
เปิดเพลงค่ะเปิดเพลงฟังเปิดเพลงหรอนัก
เรียนไม่เข้าใจเพลงอ่ะกูต้อมร้องเพลงนิ
โรจน์เทิงก็อาจะ
[เพลง]
ก็คือต้มร้องเพลงให้นักเรียนฟัง
ก็เหนื่อยแล้วร้องไม่ไหวแล้วอ่ะอันนี้
เพลงก็เปิดเพลงนะหาที่รถมีอะไรนะ Radio
หรือเปล่าคะเล็กๆเดี๋ยวค่ะ
อยู่กับเปิดเพลงฟังถ้าไม่มีก็นักเรียน
เนี่ยโทรศัพอ่ะค่ะโทรศัพท์ก็เปิดเพลงแล้ว
ก็ฟังได้ๆค่ะอ่ะกูต้อมคะถ้าคนที่เขาอยู่
ในรถเอารถติดน่ะคู่เอกเคยอ่านดูเขาบอกว่า
แต่อ่านแล้วก็เอกก็จำไม่ได้มีที่ว่าทำ
อะไร
ไม่ให้เบื่อเวลารถติดนะนอกจากฟังเพลงและ
อ๊อดเธอถ้าเป็นจากโทรศัพท์ต้องมีอุ๊เอง
ไม่มีหูฟังเสียบแล้วก็ใส่
ค่ะมีหูฟังไปไหนหมดแล้วล่ะถึงฟัง
สองคนไม่มีก็ไม่เป็นไรนะเนี่ยตังค์เพราะ
เราไม่รู้เป็นบลูทูธก็ได้
ใช่
เห
รอนักเรียนเอาไปอยู่ข้างนอกอยู่ข้างนอก
ไม่เป็นไรก็คือเสียบเข้าไปแล้วก็เอาใส่
ที่หูนะคะเราเรียกว่าหูฟังนะคะแล้วก็เปิด
เพลงจะได้ยินคนเดียวนะคะมีเดียวใช่ค่ะกู
ต้อมก็ฟังเพลงและมีอย่างอื่นไหมคะแก้
เบื่อมีอะไรอีกกูต้องไปกับลูกครูต้อมนะคะ
อีกคนนึงลูกกูต้องก็เล่นเกมในโทรศัพท์ค่ะ
เอาโทรศัพท์ว่าเล่นเกมส์
เกมส์ต่อสู้
สู้อันนี้
ไอ้กูต้องเล่นไม่ได้นะไม่ได้ต้องขับรถก็
ขับรถเนี่ยเล่นไม่ได้ฟังเพลงโอเค
กูต้องก็ฟังเพลงใช่ไหมคะก็จะ
[เพลง]
ลูกครูต้อมนั่งอยู่ข้างหลังอาหารคนต้ม
ข้างหลัง
มีคำถามค่ะ
ในรถมีกี่คน
ให้โน้ตมีสองคนค่ะโอเคกล้วยนะครูเอ๋นะ
กำลังสงสัยครูต้อม
แต่ข้างหลังอ่ะถ้ามีคนที่ 3 นั่งคิดว่า
ปวดหัวปวดหัวค่ะคิดว่าปวดหัวทำอะไร
คิดว่าจะปวดหัวนะคะทำอะไรปวดหัวแน่นอน
เลย
ค่ะนอกจากเล่นเกมราคาเล่นเกมส์ฟังเพลงถ้า
รถติดเนี่ยคนไทยทำอะไรอีกคะคุณต้อมก็ก็มี
ดู YouTube นะกูเอ๋ขอให้เดี๋ยวนี้ทุกคนมี
โทรศัพท์มือถือหนี้ให้ค่ะอันนี้เราเรียก
โทรศัพท์มือถือโทรศัพท์มือถือ
ก็ดูอะไรก็ได้ใน YouTube ให้ค่ะถ้าไม่ได้
เล่นเกมส์
ต่อสู้ก็ดู
เฮ้ยต้องดูไหมต้อมถ้ากูต้องนั่งเฉยๆนั่ง
เฉยๆกูต้องก็ดูค่ะถ้าคุยต้องขับรถกูต้อง
ดูไม่ได้นะคุณเอ๋เดี๋ยวรถ
คุณต้องครูจะเห็นนั่งแค๊กซี่
ครูเห็นแท็กซี่ดูเอ้า
จริงๆแท็กซี่
ผัดรถแล้วก็ดูเขาจะมีที่ตั้งโทรศัพท์แบบ
นี้ค่ะแล้วเขาก็เปิด
เปิดเปิดดูค่ะดูบัญชีก็ดูอะไรอ่ะดูรู้ตลก
อ่ะตลกคือมันเหมือนมิสเตอร์บีนอ่ะค่ะไม่
ค่อยตลกเขาก็ดูแล้วก็กลับหัวเราะ
คู๋น่ะตุ๊บๆ
เต้น
ผลไหมเราจะชนไหม
หัวใจกูเอกเต้นตกๆตื่นเต้นโชเฟอร์คะดูถนน
นะคะ
โอ๊ยแต่ตามินิดหน่อยไว้มากๆมาหาทำไมมาๆๆ
ถ้าวันไหนเจอคนขับอารี่แล้วดูดูดูอะไรนะ
ดูตลกหรือดูบางทีก็ดูทีวีไม่ได้ดูทีวีดู
ละครในโทรศัพท์ค่ากูเอกก็จะตื่นเต้นมาก
คู่เอกก็จะนั่งไปแล้วก็นอนโมสาร์ท
[เพลง]
โอ๊ยแต่ว่ากูเอกเข้าใจเขาจะดูเพราะว่ารถ
มันติด
รถติดไปไม่ได้ก็นะอยู่ที่นี่ครึ่งชั่วโมง
ก็โอเคดูตลก
ท่านเอกคุณต้องมีอีกวิธีเรียงน้ำทำอะไรคะ
กูต้องชอบถ่ายรูป
ถ่ายรูปเนี่ยนะคะคู๋อันนี้นี่เป็นอันนี้
เป็นเอ่อกล้องห้องถ่ายรูปใช่ไหมคะอ่ะครู
ต้มไม่ไม่ได้ใช้กล้องไม่ได้ใช้กล้องถ้า
ซ่อมใช้ใน
โทรศัพท์ค่ะถ่ายรูปถ่ายรูปใครๆตัวเอง
เซลฟี่
ออกเวลารถติดนะคะนักเรียนไม่ใช่เวลาขับรถ
เวลารถติดรถไม่ติดก็ไม่ถ่ายนะคะๆค่ะก็จะ
เป็นแบบนี้นี้กูเห็นไหมสวยนะอ๋อไม่ขาย
เก่งนะเนี่ยเวลารถติดถึงไหมคะ
อารมณ์ไหนคะตอนนั้นอย่าคาดเบลอยู่ไหมคะ
พาตเบลล์เมืองท่าแล้วก็ถามถ่ายเรื่อง
ก็จะบับไม่ปวดหัวก็ฉบับสวย
ก็ดีมากนักเรียนหญิงข้าวกูต้องเคยได้ยิน
แบบนี้ไหมบางทีคนไทยอ่ะอะที่ขับรถและเอ่อ
ออ๊อฟฟิตวันจันทร์วันอังคารวันพุธวัน
พฤหัสบดีวันศุกร์รถติดตั้งแต่นอนตื่นขึ้น
มา
07:00 น 08:00 นอ่ะนะเจ็ดโมง8โมงเช้ารถ
ติดนะคะนักเรียนรถติดเนี่ยปากบางคนก็เลย
ต้องมาที่รถแล้วก็โอเครถติดแล้วไม่เป็นไร
มี
โลชั่นอ๋อ
อ่ะมีอะไรนะอ่ะอะครีมผ้าครีมดัดแปลงหรือ
บางคนบางคนก็อันนี้ค่ะอัตราน่ารักประมาท
คิ้ว
เขียนคิ้ว
เขียนคิ้วมีบิดาอีกขอวาดนิดนึงนะคะ
Love
มีเพื่อนคนนึงนะคะมีเพื่อนคนแบ่ง
ขับรถมาทำงานนะคะขับรถนะมาทำงานครูเอ๋น่ะ
ใช้ BTS หรือรถเมล์กับเพื่อนพอดีแหละขับ
รถ
ขับรถมาทำงานนั้นเวลาขับรถน่ะรถติดเนี่ย
เปลี่ยนรถได้ไหมคะ
ไม่ได้นะเอ๋ไปได้แต่ครูเอ๋นี่ขึ้นรถเมล์
ชนะขึ้นรถเมล์ฮึด
ขึ้นรถเมล์ไปโรงเรียนไปออฟฟิศถ้ารถติดครู
เอกก็เปลี่ยนมอเตอร์ไซค์
อ้าว
คือ
มอเตอร์ไซค์แท็กซี่นะคู่เอกก็ที่นี่
มอเตอร์ไซค์ไปออฟเฟส
หรือครูเอ๋เปลี่ยนเป็น BTS
อาหมอเจอรึเปลี่ยนแท็กซี่เปลี่ยนได้แต่
ถ้าอยากครูต้อมหรือยังคนไทยขับรถเปลี่ยน
รถไม่ได้บ่ว่างเวลารถติดเนี่ยก็ต้องอยู่
ที่รถนะคะงั้นเป็นคนได้เขาก็จะดูเวลาโอ้
ไม่ได้แล้วถ้าออกช้ารถจะติดเขาจะออกจาก
บ้านประมาณ
18:30 นนะคะ
ถ้าเลยหกโมงครึ่งรถจะติดมาก
มาทับ 7 โมงอย่างเงี้ย 07:00 น
รถจะติดมากเขาก็ถ้าตอนนี้ 6 โมงครึ่งเขา
ก็จะวิ่งวิ่งแล้วก็มาที่รถนะคะก็จะโอเค
ทุกอย่างโอเคแล้วแต่ว่าคิวเนี่ยถ้าหิว
ข้าวเล็กๆเหมือนครูเอ๋น่ะ
เขาก็จะเอาคิ้วออก
มีหนึ่งว่ะ 1 วันค่ะ
มาทำงานแล้วก็มีคิ้ว
1 ข้างเอ้า
เขียนไม่ทันเหรอคะเปิดข้างนี้ก็จะแบบ
ไม่ร้อยเปอร์เซ็นต์คือคิ้วคิ้วสวยๆแบบ
เนี้ย 1 คางอีกข้างเหมือนคิ้วมีนิดหน่อย
อ่ะ
มีนิดหน่อยคือเอกกินนิดหน่อย
[เพลง]
แต่ว่าครูเอ๋เป็นคนไม่เขียนคิ้วน่ะกูอีก
อ่ะเห้ยทำไมคิ้วมันไม่เหมือนกันเฮ้อบอก
ไม่คุณต้อมเนี่ย
บอกเถอะบอกด้วยว่าเอกเวลาจะบอกต้องขอ
โทษก่อนนะ
ขอโทษค่ะ
มีเพื่อนถามอะไรอะไรเอ๋เออวันนี้เขียน
แฟชั่นใหม่หรอ New  Fashion
มีมิกซ์คิ้วแบบนี้กับคิ้วแบบนี้อ่ะคิ้ว
ข้างขวากับข้างซ้ายไม่เหมือนกันคู๋ไม่รู้
fashion  cute ตอนนี้แฟชั่นอะไรก็ถาม
เพื่อนตอนนี้มีแฟนชั่นใหม่เหรอคะคิ้วไม่
เหมือนกันนะคิวก็เอกก็ไม่เหมือนกันนะ
เพื่อนก็บอกว่าเอ๊ยใช่ทำไม
หรอโอเคดูกระจกมีกระจก
แล้วก็มาที่นี่แล้วก็ดูเห็นตัวเอง
เพื่อ
เขียนคิ้วได้ข้างเดียวแล้วลืมลืมได้เขียน
คิ้วตอนรถติดพี่ขอ
รถติดก็เลยเขียนแม็กซ์เขียนคิ้วทำตาแต่ง
หน้าแล้วรถก็ไปเพื่อนก็โอเคไป
ถึงออฟฟิศก็ลงจากรถลืมเขียนคิ้วข้างซ้าย
โอเค
เราก็เดินสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะทุกคน
อะไรนะฮะถ้าปากไหมคะเพื่อนตัวเองเท้าปาก
เสร็จแล้วมีคิ้ว
ไม่ทันไปไฟเวลารถติดใช่ไหมคะตรงนี้มันจะ
มีไฟไปจะมีไฟแดงถ้า
ไปเหลืองใช่ไหมใส่ส้มค่ะอ่ะ
ต่อไปเขียว
เวลาไฟเขียวนะแปลว่าไปใช่ไหมค่ะไฟแดง
เนี่ยแปลว่าหยุด
เวลาไฟแดงปั๊ปเนี่ยไฟแดงปุ๊ปเนี่ยเขาก็
หยุดแล้วก็โอเคเขียนคิ้วแต่ว่าพอไฟเขียว
ทุกคนต้องออกเขาก็โอเคออกอะไรดื่ม
q1 ข้างหอ
นั่นแหละก็ก็สามารถอะไรนะแต่งหน้าแต่ง
หน้าในรถในรถได้เวลารถติดเวลารถติดทำอะไร
อีกค่ะคุณต้อมกูต้องมีเพื่อนเพื่อนคนนึง
เขาจะชอบช้อปปิ้งออนไลน์ขอ
กดโทรศัพท์
of วิ่งค่ะถ้ารถติดมากๆก็ซื้อเยอะเลย
เยอะมากค่ะ O คุณหมอ
วะดูเสร็จแล้วอ่ะภาษาไทยภาษาคนชอบซื้อของ
ออนไลน์เขาได้มือลั่นใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะมือลั่น
กดกดค่ะกดแล้วก็ดูแล้วก็
สั่งแล้ว
ช้างใช่ๆแต่ครูต้อมไม่ซื้อซื้อชอปปิ้ง
ออนไลน์ตอนรถติดนะครูเอ๋ทำไมล่ะคะเขาว่า
ครูต้องต้องคิดเยอะอ๋อดีค่ะกูต้องเพราะรถ
ติดนานๆถ้าชอบชอบซื้อของออนไลน์จะจะซื้อ
เยอะค่ะ
เมื่อก่อนกูต้องตอนรถติดนะกูต้อมหวีด
นิสัยไม่ดีอย่างนึงอะไรหรือไหมอะไรคะคุณ
ต้องอ่ะชอบบีบบีบ
บีบสิวไม่ดีไหมดีไม่ดีวิธีค้นหาเลือดออก
หลังมีเงินถ้าคำรถเองนี้ก็ทำอะไรยากเนาะ
งั้นไม่ดีนะบีบสิวไม่ดีนะที่ไม่ดีทำอะไร
ได้อีก
โทรศัพท์
โทรศัพท์คุยกับแฟนถ้าแล้วก็
ฟังคอร์ด Cash ออกมันเรียนเนาะเรียวๆค่ะ
เหมือนเรียนหนังสือไปด้วยเพราะว่า
รถติด 1 ชั่วโมง 2 ชั่วโมงก็ฟังฟังจบไป 2
เรื่อง 3 เรื่องอันนี้กูต้องขับรถน่ะ
ขับรถก็ขับรถคนเดียวก็สั่งได้ค่ะฝันได้
อ่านหนังสือได้ไหมคะคุยก็มีทั้งหนังสือ
ไม่ได้นะคะ
ถ้ากูต้องขับรถเนี่ยอ่านไม่ได้จ้าคนที่
นั่งข้างหลังอ่านได้ไหมคะอ่านได้ค่ะมากรถ
ติดนะคะนักเรียนรถวิ่งแบบไม่อ่านนะคะรถ
บิดอ่านหนังสือได้นะคะกูเอกชอบทำอะไรรู้
ไหมคะอะไรคะคุณเอ๋ต้องคิดคู๋ทำอะไร
ฮู๋
แม่จะคุยโทรศัพท์หรือเปล่าคะ
มายไม่รถติดหรอว่า
เมื่อก่อนเวลาเด็กๆอ่านหนังสือเวลารถติด
อ่านหนังสือมากๆ
แต่ตอนนี้มั้ยไม่ได้ไม่ตัดชุด
ตัดเล็บในรถไม่ได้ไม่ร้องไม่ต้องใครตัด
เล็บในรถไม่ดีอ่ะอ๋อรถตัวเองใช่ไหมคะก็
เองโอเคโอเคกูเอไม่ได้ขับรถคุณต้องคุยไป
แท็กซี่บ่เคยไปแท็กซี่กลับไปอ่ะ
bts ไปรถเมล์ตัดเล็บไม่ได้ค่ะ
นี่ทำอะไร
ไม่ทำอะไรหวีผมนอนค่ะ
เราเอ้าน้องเขาก็ขับไปแล้ว
คุยบอกทางเขาไม่คะเลี้ยวซ้ายเลี้ยวขวากู
ไอ้ต้องบอกคะนั้นแท็กซี่ก็บอกวันที่หลับ
นานนั้นแท็กซี่จะพูดพี่ครับลงสุขุมวิท 50
ใช่ไหมครับ
ขึ้นขึ้นขึ้นพื้นถนนน่ะมันมีถนนตรงๆกับ
ถนนข้างบนถนนข้างบนเนี่ยเรียกว่าทางด่วน
ไม่ฟรี
50 บาทคะนักเรียนปางเสียตังค์ได้แบบทาง
ด่วนก็รถติดครูอย่าหลับพระหลับเสร็จแล้ว
เนี่ยแท็กซี่
ที่ไหนถ้ารถออกไปแท็กซี่กันบอกพี่ครับคุย
กับพี่คอปโอ้ยนี่ครับ
เลี้ยวซ้ายเลี้ยวขวา
หลับบ่อยๆบางทีบางทีสามีหลับโค๊ทตื่นแต่
บางทีสองคนหลับแท็กซี่ก็ไปไหน
ธาตุบางวันโอเคนะคะแต่ถ้าเป็นกลางคืน
มืดเนี้ยค่ะหลับไม่ดียิ่งเป็นผู้หญิงก็
ไม่มีลำจะขึ้นทางด่วนไงทางด่วนโอเคแต่กู
เองก็จะหลับตาจริงๆหลับตาแล้วก็เผลอหลับ
ล่ะตลับแป๊ปเดียว
มันแบบเดียวแต่แป๊บเดียวเนี่ยมันก็ที่ไหน
อันนี้ก็ไม่คะใช่ค่ะ
BTS โอเคไหมนั่งหลับไม่โอเคอ๋ออ๋อก็ไม่
รถเมล์รถเมล์ไม่โอเคใช่หรอเดี๋ยวมีข้อมูล
ใช่
โอเคแล้วเขามีคนอื่นทำอะไรอีกนะคะเวลาที่
รถติดมีคนอื่น
on เขาจะไลฟ์สดอ่ะค่ะถ่ายวีดีโอ
อ่อนล้าเป็นไผ่เปอร์ราคายูทูปเบอร์ก็จะ
ถ่ายวีดีโอถ่ายถ่ายตอนนี้นะคะอยู่ที่ห้าง
นี้นะคะเอ่ออย่างนี้นะคะรถมันเป็นรถติด
มากค่ะรถติดมากค่ะแล้วก็พูดกูๆๆพูดคน
เดียวคนเดียวขออ๋อคุณต้องทำไมอ่ะไม่ค่อย
ทำค่ะกูแต่บางคนก็ไม่ใช่ยูทูปเบอร์นะคะ
ขายตัวเองแล้วที่โพสต์ลง Facebook
ค่ะกูต้มรถติดส่วนใหญ่ปิดเพราะอะไรอ่ะฝน
ตกด้วยไหม
สิเขาว่ารถเยอะมากๆแล้วก็เป็นเปิดเทอมค่ะ
เด็กนักเรียนก็ไปโรงเรียน
หน้าแล้วก็โควิชคนไม่ work  from  home
ที่บ้านแล้วฝนก็ออกมาทำงานข้างนอก
ชายค่ะรถจะเริ่มติดนะคะอ๋อแล้ววันนี้เป็น
วันอาทิตย์ค่ะสิ้นเดือนครูเอ๋เอ๋วันที่ 20
เดี๋ยวสิ้นเดือนคือขอโทษค่ะสิ้นเดือนคือ
วันที่วันที่
29  30  31 จะขอเขาบอกนักเรียนหน่อย
นิดนึงอ้าโอเคนักเรียนอันนี้ปฏิทินนะคะ
ประทีป
ถ้าแปลแบบก็มี 1  2  3  4  5  6  7 เนาะ
ก็จะมีวันอาทิตย์นะคะวันจันทร์วันอังคาร
วันพุธวัน
พฤหัสบดีวันศุกร์วันเสาร์นะคะถ้าวันที่ 1
วันที่ 2 เนี่ยเราเรียกว่าต้นเดือนเดือน
ค่ะวันที่
28  29
30  31
ตรงนี้ล่ะค่ะ
วันสิ้นเบื่อง
เวลาดูปฏิทินใช่ไหมคะนักเรียนปฏิทินหนัง
เดือนนี้เดือน
เดือนเมษาพฤษภาคมเดือนพฤษภาคมก็กำลังจะ
สิ้นเดือนวันนี้วันที่ 20  29 สิ้นเดือน 4
เดือนแล้วทำไมคะสิ้นเดือนเงินเดือนออกข้า
ครูเอ๋
เงินใช่ไหมคนที่ไปออฟฟิศทำงานทำงาน 30
วันก็จะได้เงินนะคะ
ออฟฟิศให้เงินมีเงินกลับบ้านนอนโอเค
ไม่กลับบ้านนอนนะคะไม่กากมีเงินก็ต้องไป
ช้อปปิ้งอ้าไปซื้อของทุกคนไปซื้อของไป
ช้อปปิ้งค่ะ
วายซื้อแว่นนะคะข้าวกับเพื่อนกินข้าวกับ
แฟน
[เพลง]
คนทุกคนออกมานอกบ้านกันหมดเลยวันสิ้น
เดือนค่ะชอบซื้อก็เลยติดติดๆจริงๆไม่รู้
นักเรียนชอบซื้อไหมหนอแต่สิ้นเดือนน่ะไป
รถซื้อไว้คุยสงสัยจังเลยกูแต่สิ้นเดือน
เนี่ยซึ่งเดือนนี้โอ๊ย
ห้างหรือซุปเปอร์มาร์เก็ตนะชอบมากคนไทยไป
ซื้อนะคะมีลดราคาเยอะๆใช่ไหม
ครูเอชอบไปช่วงกลางเดือนกูต้อมขอคนไม่มี
คนนิดหน่อยอ๋อคนนิดหน่อยสิ้นเดือนน่ะครู
เอ๋ไม่ไปซื้อไม่รู้ IQ คู๋ดีไม่ดีนะแต่กู
เอกชอบไปกลางๆเดือนอ่ะ
ไม่ไปแต่สิ้นเดือนน่ะเขาจะแบบ
20% วัชราคาคู๋ใช่คนก็เลยชอบไปราคา
ให้ค่ะตอนนี้ก็มี shopping  online นะ
หลายๆคน
และก็ถ้ามีอะไรทำใช่ไหมคะนักเรียนเวลารถ
ติดแล้วเรานั่งเฉยๆมันจะเบื่อแล้วก็
เหนื่อย
แต่ว่าพระหาอะไรทำนะคะหาอะไรทำมันก็สนุก
ใช่ไหมคะๆค่ะเด็กๆก็เล่นเกมอ่ะครูต้อมก็
ฟังฟังเพลงฟังเพลงนะคะบางคนป่ะอ่าน
หนังสือ
นะบางคนออกกำลังกายคือต้องอุ้ย
ได้นะหรอได้ทำยังไงกูต้องอยู่แบบเนี้ย
เมื่อยไหมมึงไม่ก็
หน่อยใช่ไหมคะนิดโอ้
ยืดแขนนี่หน่อยใช่เขาเรียกว่าออกกำลังกาย
ขอฝันยืดแขนอย่างเดียวแต่ว่ายกขาขึ้นมา
ไม่ได้ยกขา
เอ่อคนขับรถไม่ได้ไม่ท้อข้างหลังโอเค
ยกแขนอย่างเดียวได้ได้ได้ต้องยกขา
นะเช้าเราก็อยากจะรู้ไหมว่านักประเทศนัก
เรียนรถติดไหมกูต้องอย่างรู้ไหมค่ะอยาก
รู้ค่ารถติดไหมคะอ่านักเรียนคอมเม้นท์บอก
ครูหน่อยนะคะ
ที่บ้านนักเรียนรถติดไหมแล้วถ้ารถติดนัก
เรียนทำอะไรนะคะที่ในรถนะคะถ้าเบื่อรถติด
เนี่ยนักเรียนทำอะไรนั่งอ่านหนังสืออ่า
นอนหลับ
หรือว่าบางบังเพลงถ้าขับรถก็ร้องเพลงได้
นะคะแบบท่านนั่งแท็กซี่ร้องเพลงไม่ได้นะ
แม้
แต่คู่เอกเคยเคยเห็นอันนึงนะมีคนนั่งรถ
และเปิดหน้าต่าง
[เพลง]
โรงแล้วฝนตกไงมีคนนึงอ่ะคิดว่าโกรธมาก
เลือกเปิดหน้าต่างแล้วก็เปิดหน้าต่างกัน
เค้าขับด้านนี้นะเปิดแล้วก็โผล่หัวมาแล้ว
ก็
ขอ
อร่อยเสียงดังๆตัวเองอุ้ยแต่ว่าอุ้ยสวยกู
เองสนุก
ตลกตลกขอบคุณค่ะขอบคุณค่ะหัด
แต่แท็กซี่บอก Oh โอ้ไม่สบายหรือเปล่า
ไม่คุยกับขอบคุณค่ะสรุปดีสบายดีไหมค่ะ
อา
โอเคค่ะวันนี้วันนี้หมดเวลาน้องเอ๋
ไม่ไกลนักเรียนทำอะไรเวลารถติดบอกเราด้วย
นะคะเดี๋ยวครูต้องกับผู้ที่ไปก่อนนะคะ
ก่อนนะไปนอนพักผ่อนกันนะคะเธอเธอสวัสดี
ค่ะคุณต้องคุณค่าครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนม